today President Trump will meet with a
bipartisan group of House lawmakers to
discuss issues such as health care daca
and tax reform
this morning the president tweeted quote
the approval process for the biggest tax
cut and tax reform package in the
history of our country will soon begin
move fast Congress last night mr. Trump
posted several senators at the White
House for a dinner to discuss taxes
Senator Joe Manchin of West Virginia was
among three Democratic senators to
accept the invitation he joins us now
from Capitol Hill center to mansion good
morning good morning Charlie how are you
I was dinner he's good it was a really
good dinner always a good dinner at the
White House that was my first dinner
sit-down dinner so it was excellent with
any president of with its president just
this president no no any President this
is the first time that I've gone to a
personal sit down dinner I've been to
state dinners things of that sort when I
was governor and all but since I've been
a senator this is my first so with that
opportunity what did you hope to achieve
and did you achieve it well I thought it
was a very open dialogue it was very
free-flowing open we talked about a lot
of things you know infrastructure was
very much on the president's mind and
his staff and we talked in depth about
what we could do the innovation and
creation of the future and what we
should be and what's going on around the
world and that was exciting and I think
that's going to happen we're all
committed to infrastructure I said
potholes don't have a Republican or
Democrats name on it they just need
fixed so that's what we're working on
and we're talking about that and then we
got into the tacks and it got really
interesting I think they're very
aggressive on this they want it done
they want it in a bipartisan way I
thought it was very good for them to
reach out to us we had a I think an
in-depth conversation on our concerns
the president was adamant this is not a
tax cut for the rich and that's exactly
what people will portray but he says it
is not going to happen I can assure you
it's going to be mostly for middle class
the working people or we're going to be
competitive or globally competitive so
I'm anxious to see the results and I've
said my main concern was Charlie that no
new debt I mean we're 20 trillion I have
10 grandchildren I can't look at these
beautiful babies and say guess what
we're giving you I'm curious to see how
that gets done with known
debt that's always been sort of sticky
widget with with tax reform and one of
them repealing the estate tax that's
gonna cost an ad about two hundred
seventy billion dollars over the over a
decade would Democrats support that I
don't think you know that's hard to
support just eliminating this state tax
or death tax as we know it right now
it's at 5 million individually ten
million a couple can that maintain could
it increase a little bit and help those
people farmers and small businesses that
want to leave them to their children
that's something we're all concerned
about and we're looking at they were
very open it wasn't like a closed shut
door nor it wasn't like this is it this
is what you're going to get the tax rate
there whether it be the corporate tax
rate it needs to be competitive globally
competitive we talked about the global
average we talked about everything in
depth to where they're willing to say
okay let's look at this how we make this
work but I thought it was very engaging
I I enjoyed it well listen I have to say
it sounds very promising you know the
president was unable to repeal Obamacare
dealing with only Republicans recently
he made a deal with the Democrats lift
the debt ceiling do you think that this
is a new way of doing business for this
White House well here's the way that we
should be doing business in Washington
we should be looking at legislation that
can garner in the Senate 30 Democrats 30
Republicans we're not going to get the
fringes we're just not going to do that
but we've got to find the middle for the
sake of this country and that's what
West Virginians expect for me that's
what they want and that's what we're
looking to do so I do you think that
this is a new way of working and why I
know you say this is how it should be is
this the way it's going to be do you
think well let's just say that he
reached out to Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi and looking at making I think
that was a strategic move it was good
move saying okay we'll link both what
the deal is that can be made on taxes
yes I think forgives up what but what
well first of all tax reform or tax cuts
whatever you want to do has to be done
to where it stimulates the economy grows
the economy on a global basis its
competitive you know we didn't create
the market global market but we've got
to compete in it next of all we can't
continue to add to twenty trillion
dollars so you have to be very sensitive
know
or debt you can't add on that we've got
to see a pathway forward to start
bringing this that down and get
ourselves fiscally responsible and I
think that's what that conversation was
last night and what I heard and willing
to you know really isn't willing to
explore all avenues of this
understanding that Democrats responsible
moderate some of us conservative
Democrats who are looking for fiscal
responsibility and you know I've always
said this I'm fiscally responsible and
socially compassionate senator before
you go we got to go but before you go
what was the menu chicken beef fish what
was it it was a met it was a medallion
it was a gift medallion and it was well
I hate to pry but did you have one scoop
or two scoops of ice cream no no we had
let me tell you the ice cream was so
perfectly prepared the ice cream came
beside the dessert deal and that looked
like an egg and I said I wonder why I'm
getting an egg with my dessert and I cut
into it and it was a it was a
beautifully sculptured ice cream okay
the president said to love dessert did
you did he eat more desserts than you no
he did not
no he did not that that I think that is
a misnomer I'm sound like a good dinner
guest to me Joe my no thank you very
much for joining thank you for all the
details
thank you all give everybody take them
inside the room Thank You senator